for this first story we're not throwing
it to a website I'm gonna throw it to
Eliza apparently uh you've got something
to say yes I do
um so before I say what I'm about to say
um I just want to let everyone know that
I serve these survivors speaking here as
their Survivor Advocate and to anyone
that needs more information I will be
giving information at the end of this so
if survivors need to step forward and as
always anytime I'm on a show just know
that you can reach out to the human
trafficking hotline at any time I can
also give that number throughout this
stream as well
so let's get it going um so I tonight I
might use the word allegedly at certain
points um this has been advised by legal
um not because I don't believe the
survivors that I serve but it's the
legal way to do it so let's get it going
this is an official press release
these are not my words these this is a
survivor
as a survivor of the Tate Brothers I
understand how difficult it can be to
come forward and speak out about what
happened to you
but when social media gives us a glimpse
into the extreme harm that others cause
I feel obligated to step forward and
speak out against it
if these words can prevent one woman
from being an alleged victim of Andrew
and Tristan Tate
it justifies the risk that I'm taking
it can be scary overwhelming and you may
feel like you don't have anyone to turn
to
if you or someone you know is a survivor
know that you are not alone and that
there is help available
by coming forward together
we may be able to find Justice for
ourselves and prevent these perpetrators
from hurting anyone else
it is Bray it is a brave and important
step towards healing and finding closure
I know it can be hard to take this first
step but I promise you that there are
resources and people ready and available
to help you through this process don't
let fear or shame keep you from speaking
out let this be a reminder that you
deserve to be heard to feel safe and
supported you have you have the absolute
right to seek Justice this is a moment
and an opportunity for any victim of
these alleged perpetrators to stand up
and together we can recognize
vulnerability as power see the strength
in numbers and shine light on strength
of every single Survivor signed an
anonymous Survivor
the second statement
uh this will be Survivor two
for women who have been victimized we
didn't know the game
that was being played to hurt us
we know a game we know we didn't know a
game was being played at all
it's only after it happens and you lose
that and you lose that you know
whether the Loverboy method or some
other way
victims know that this game of deception
is used in in the court of public
opinion today
to the people who've made assumptions
about the victims before trial trial I
forgive you
I'm sorry
I won't ask
I won't ask
I won't ask those people to change their
opinion for our sake
I would just ask them to consider one
thing what if you're wrong
is it possible
and if it is
you can wait for the court to do its job
before attacking
those who those who have gone about the
correct legal process for justice
to all the victims out there I know you
I know how wounded you feel I have felt
that way too
I love each and every one of you for
being bragan brave enough to move
forward despite those feelings you are
loved
and know how strong you and and many
know how strong you have been signed
Anonymous Survivor
so if you are a survivor
of Andrew Tate
Tristan Tate or any co-conspirators in
this case
I need you to visit the website
n-c-o-s-e.com
ncose.com you'll see a click through
it'll go straight to the legal team
that's representing these two survivors
and I have a message of support
from a survivor of Epstein
Survivor of Epstein Maxwell Teresa J
helm
my support empathy and immense respect
to these courageous survivors brave
enough braving through the storm and
coming forward each of these women have
the soul of a warrior and the Heart of a
lioness
to the women to the women coming forward
and speaking to you you are changing the
world and hold and halting the vile
systems of exploitation make no mistake
you are a hero
you speak for so many that have yet to
breathe life into their words you are
taking your power back you are returning
you are returning it to where it has
always belonged within you
Justice is a journey and I encourage you
to to use each footstep to imprint your
Fierce will fight back demand
accountability drain the shame that was
never yours whoo that's cold uh to the
survivors that are currently developing
your strength to step to take that first
step of coming forward we are suited up
and you have an army of Warriors ready
to lock arms with you and that's true
take take the step reach out we are here
to help you and build a foundation of
your pathway to Justice
they they throughout they thought they
thought they'd bury you break three
Break Free through the barrier of
Silence take your power back with love
respect to each of you God bless you
Teresa J Helm Teresa J Helm is now
working full-time at nicosi and nicosi
law will be representing the survivors
the American survivors and Western
survivors
so the Undertake case what do we know
about what Andrew Tate was doing what
what what do we have in terms of hard
facts so just based off my relationship
I'm not going to speak too too much
about
um you know the case but I will be
posting those statements onto my Twitter
account at elizablue sorry I cried too
um Eliza blue
I'll be putting them there and then
survivors if you miss the the
um you know website to reach out you can
reach out there
um what we know
is that there are
um there are some folks that uh want to
get some justice
that's what we know that's what I know
so just to clarify that these are two
victims that are coming forward but
they're choosing to remain anonymous and
I'll tell you why and and I heard kind
of two words here trafficking and lover
boy yeah are those the main accusations
and are they suing for damages or are
they suing to get uh them arrested so
really quickly
um
the survivors are remaining Anonymous
and this was like a last minute decision
a day because of fear
um a fear as a result the legal team is
afraid for their safety
um and that's where we're at I'm in the
United States safety I'm afraid for my
own safety even sitting here speaking
about this
um
so that's where we're at with it um so
we need to make sure before those
survivors step forward uh if they do if
and when they choose because it's always
up to the Survivor you can be a part of
a lawsuit and be a Jane or John Doe
right
um but if and when these survivors
decide to step forward we need to make
sure that they are safe and this goes to
any Survivor out there that's listening
if you decide to step forward in this
case either as a Jane Doe or whatever
um but so this is a monetary lawsuit
then
if they're if they're remaining
Anonymous it's not going to be a
criminal proceeding in the United States
at least we'll see where it goes I mean
it depends on whom ever steps forward
you get what I'm saying but I mean if
this if this goes to a lawsuit then it's
a civil case where they can remain
anonymous if they can't remain anonymous
and if it's a choice between life or
death then we will not have them step
forward if it's not it's always up to
the Survivor no no you said you're not
comfortable speaking about the evidence
here
um can you say that you did see did you
see any evidence yourself if you can't
if you can't tell us about this I'm not
going to speak about it and are you
confident or like
um from from what your information that
you're getting is this a solid case
from your experience working in this
kind of particular field
because I know there's still a lot of
things up in the air we still don't know
a lot but from from your kind of
understanding of how all this works um
how do you see this case I believe the
survivors that I serve and now leave
that there
do you trust the justice system if it
goes forward
um it's the system that we have yeah so
it doesn't really matter whether or not
I trust it it's the system that we have
does this temp to have like because I
have my own opinion on everything right
but uh I do everything legally
unlawfully and that's how we'll do it I
wish that there was a different system
but I can't live constantly in Utopia I
have to take action today the the main
challenge I have first I want to stress
have have there's a lot of people
defending Andrew Tate and by all means I
I have not watched everything he's ever
put out but I have seen a portion of of
uh many different podcasts people have
sent me I don't take those with a lot of
weight because out of contact statements
don't sway me seeing a 30 second or even
a four minute clip of Andrew Tate
talking about something I'll be like
okay I'll consider that he said that
I'll have heard that he said that but
without listening to the full hour I
don't like people being like Oh actually
I'll give an example
I thought people come to me and they're
like did you hear what Dave Rubin said
and I'll be like what did Dave Rubin say
and they'll be like he said this thing
and then I'll be like how do you know he
said that someone posted a clip on
Twitter and I'll be like come on bro
they post clips of me out of context all
the time I don't know if yeah that being
said Andrew Tate tells this story
frequently about how he had a bunch of
women who loved him and he said I'm
broke come come here we're gonna make
money and that he started a cam business
so there's there's a few questions the
first thing the first thing I'll say is
I understand why people are skeptical
we've not actually seen any evidence
from Romania other than accusations and
to be honest even the statements that
you have so so far didn't actually
assert anything
it's just people saying they were
survivors and they're looking for more
people to come forward sure
um so I mean what that's that's the
first step I suppose but for the time
being that's why the lawyers probably
said say allegedly because
we've not heard anything other than he
convinced women to go and work for him
and that it was it was exploitation and
illegitimate that he was a lover boy
that he was telling him how much he
loved him come out and then actually was
just putting him into these situations
so those accusations are there I guess
people are saying outside of uh I will
say this these State these Anonymous
statements but also Vice put out a video
that allegedly comes from Witnesses we
have circumstantial evidence
the other thing I'll add to it is I can
also understand why people are skeptical
on this because
we've not gotten any accountability from
Epstein despite the fact that that guy
got arrested Maxwell was convicted we
know there were people flying on his
plane we know some of the people who are
on this island some of these names have
been released and there's been literally
nothing done on it but then Andrew take
it's rated so people are asking
questions is it that Andrew Tate gained
power in a way that was outside of the
Epstein you know group and thus he's not
protected I'm releasing my own statement
later tonight might clear a little bit
of that up yeah like my statement's a
little different my statements come
straight at the at the throat but it's a
little long to read on your show to be
honest but like Andrew Tate didn't
donate to Democrats is that why he gets
arrested so I think there's a lot of
people who are just like we don't we
don't believe it because if they really
cared about trafficking they'd have gone
after this whole list I mean like Luke
named off a ton of people already who
were implicated that they never went
after so this is why people are just
like I don't buy it and Andrew like I'm
not I'm not saying I know I look I don't
know anything about Andrew Tate only a
little only a little bit right but I can
certainly understand why people are
skeptical if you get a guy who comes out
and tells people to break free from the
machine get away from the Matrix be
masculine and then they're like they ban
them from every platform then arrest
them he's never said any he doesn't say
anything that like Luke doesn't say like
I mean seriously like literally it's not
like he's like Reinventing the wheel and
I don't want to get too much into his I
I have no opinion on him and I I I'm
gonna let the Court decide I really will
um and I'll I'll go with that whatever
but I mean literally it's not like he's
coming out and like saying anything
that's super groundbreaking or you know
it's he's not Julian Assange
right you know what I mean he's not
Edward Snowden you know what I mean like
people act like uh you know like Tate's
saying something new or unique it's like
stuff that people like Luke and I say on
a daily basis like any day that ends in
y if he did what he's accused of doing
him and his brother then he needs to be
brought to Justice yeah but honestly I
understand why people find it hard to
believe when there's zero accountability
for the entire list of Epstein's clients
like the one that we haven't seen but
I'm talking about you know Bill Gates
flying on his plane Bill Clinton flying
on his plane things like that and
there's just no question don't talk
about it get the F out and then not to
mention you've got FTX where they're
trying they're going as light as
possible on this guy and obviously this
guy's a financial related thing but
these people in the club they get away
with everything so it very well may be
that Andrew Tate did bad stuff but he
ain't in the club and he's been speaking
out against the club so he's not
protected as we know for many decades
now the the federal government has been
aiding and protecting some of the worst
atrocious horrible behaviors
um they've been working with big Tech
social media that also has been aiding
and abetting it to the point where
there's even victims coming forward and
saying hey there's these photos there's
these videos of me being an underage
child being hurt and abused here Twitter
looking at that listening to the victim
still deciding you know what this
doesn't violate our terms and policies
this is what happened here in the United
States your tax dollars as an American
went to aiding and protecting an
international trafficking operation were
off off of the coast and the Virgin
Islands in the United States they
literally had an island that they flew
in powerful people and they procured
small children to them so obviously this
is a very important issue here this is
an issue that we can't forget this is an
issue that we need to to fight for since
everything that usually happens in our
Mainline political system is protecting
these individuals and very rarely do we
get any justice here now when it comes
to this particular case I I know you
don't feel comfortable talking about
some of the accusations or some of the
evidence here so I'm just I'm just
trying to to frame some questions so we
get a kind of bigger understanding here
um if I could ask
um did do you know these victims
beforehand did they come to the law firm
can you tell us a little bit about your
background with them and did you talk to
them and from like zero to a hundred how
much do you trust them
[Music]
all right for me right now Luke this is
a little different than the than the
John Doe one gender 2 Twitter lawsuit I
mean once things are filed then I have
green light to go right now I'm in limbo
as a Survivor Advocate I've been serving
one of the survivors since summer since
since this past summer so I've been
serving this individual on a frequent
basis as their Survivor Advocate giving
direct service anyone that knows what a
victim's Advocate is or as a Survivor
advocate so I've been working with this
individual for quite some time the other
Survivor is more recent the
and that's all I'm going to say about
that right now just to not I don't want
to um break any of their it's I have to
be very mindful of what I say because I
don't want to give away any of their
identity from your experience you 100
believe them
um I believe every Survivor that I serve
but I also do my part in explaining due
diligence I'm sorry explaining do I do
my due diligence and explaining due
process yeah because some people are
gonna you know take that question and
are saying well if you believe everyone
how do we know if someone's not you know
using this situation for their own
personal benefits and I could see that
um well number one they don't get any
money from me and they don't get I mean
as you can see they're not even coming
out their full name yet by the way they
will they these two survivors probably
will we just need to make sure that
they're safe
um you have to understand we're we
didn't necessarily know that the
Romanian law enforcement was going to
move ahead with what they did right then
so um so it's it's putting the other
survivors that have been building their
case globally for a while we're all in
like hyper mode
um trying to
not catch up but sort of catch up and I
want to kind of uh sorry go ahead keep
why you why do you call them survivors
why is that the terminology
because I'm a Survivor Advocate no but
like what does Survivor mean like is
there a survivor of abuse or trauma does
that mean that there's a hyperpence like
the end result of the trauma or abuse is
to kill them
that's a really good point Tim
um I believe that anytime someone faces
trauma in this way uh sexual assault
domestic violence human trafficking that
there is a high potential especially in
Children of their life to end right then
and there you never know how violent
it's going to get
um and that's it's funny I think
sometimes people think I'm like kind of
a nut job because I'm so grateful to be
alive all the time I don't think they
understand what I've fully been through
if you anyone that survived that type of
trauma is very grateful to be alive
because sometimes I think about the
times I could have died and I'm shocked
that I didn't
so yes they survived they have survived
the trauma um in legal terms you say
victim
right I think I think a lot of people
take issue with the term Survivor
because okay Survivor is like you know
you survived a building collapse you
survived a murderer or you survived yeah
and and you know survive means to live
like it it I guess I suppose I would
Define it as living through something
which may have taken your life you
survived it's uh you're a survivor of a
shipwreck so I guess the question is and
I'm not saying it's not true you know
for a lot of these women I could imagine
that they do end up dead especially when
it comes to the more serious
international trafficking yeah they'll
get they get forced onto drugs into
opioid onto opiates because it'll make
them more manageable and then many of
them do die from this my my concern is I
I wouldn't I wouldn't say basically the
accusations on the entertain thing it's
probably iffy I think the issue is a lot
of leftists a lot of woke people will
call themselves survivors when it's like
someone said nasty things to them or
like they got into a fight in the street
you know what I mean I don't like the
word victim per se though because victim
means you're staying there
oh I hate it when people call me a
victim
that's one of my main complaints
sometimes uh corporate press or other
people on Twitter will say oh she's a
victim she's a victim I'm not a victim
I'm a survivor
so I I survived and I don't want to stay
in victim mentality and I don't want to
live there and I've chosen not to so
what else what other word would I say
I'm someone who has experienced uh you
know survivors a shorthand for an
individual who has experienced that
specific trauma this is interesting yeah
we don't want to be victims we don't
want to live in victimhood that's part
of the problem with whiteness everything
makes them a victim so I can certainly
understand someone saying no I'm not a
victim I'm a Survivor then you get
people on the right who are like you
didn't survive you weren't going to die
you know what I mean so it's like I I
agree I wouldn't want to say victim
either because you don't want to put
yourself in a weakened State you want
you want to rise above and move forward
with it right yeah I guess people are
just asking you know what what is the
Nuance here is this related to kind of
because because abuse takes many forms
is this psychological abuse is this
being a lover boy or is this you know
running a human trafficking operation
where you're procuring children or small
people what what kind of degrees are we
talking about here I think that's what a
lot of people are asking sure let's
break something down really quickly I
don't hate the term lover boy but I kind
of do lover boy is a is a almost like a
slang for the coercive human trafficking
is force fraud or coercion for the sale
of Labor or sex lover boy would fall
under the coercive aspect if you are
coerced into uh you know sex or labor
trafficking that would be sort of what
the lover boy the reason why I don't
prefer lover boys because women can be
traffickers so that to me that's not a
good I like to say coerced if
individuals were coerced into
um sexual exploitation that's what and
and I am a survivor of a coercive
relationship too unfortunately I ran a
poll and uh we have about seven thousand
four hundred seven thousand three
hundred votes and climbing do you think
Andrew Tate is guilty 84 said no
okay I mean that's fine I mean even the
Survivor said just let it you know let
the courts do their thing even though
even when the survivors said that in in
their statement but um you know I will
say this to those who want to support
survivors please do during this time um
whether it be myself the survivors of
Epstein Maxwell or the so the um alleged
survivors of Tate uh
please do because they're um their
supporters are very loud
um the Bots are very loud
and I think it would be very helpful if
you're a supporter of survivors if you
speak out I think advice
skepticism like this though is a maybe a
consequence of the oversaturation of
false allegations from like a lot of the
last few years and like I was telling
people when those were happening like
the consequence of this is going to be
when people do step forward no one's
going to believe it anymore this is the
tale as well this time people haven't
believed survivors since they started
stepping forward and they've only
recently said you know let me just say
real quick when Alex Jones was talking
about Epstein he was called crazy in a
conspiracy theorist and now 10 12 13
however long it's been all of a sudden
it's like well of course get whip out
that Alex Jones was right jars look man
I'm gonna I'll put it this way I
understand a lot of people like Andrew
Tate and they probably do because he's
telling them to step up push Back
Against the Machine and he's had several
videos that we've praised notably where
he said whether I really I really love
it says whether I'm happy or unhappy is
irrelevant when I if I wake up unhappy I
can do the exact same thing I would do
if I I was happy and I'm like that's a
really good point he had another video
where he said you gotta keep working you
can't stop rocket ship going to the Moon
doesn't stop halfway to chill out no it
loses momentum and it falls you got to
keep going people hear those messages
they're positive messages he says don't
abide by the machine break free from The
Matrix take the red pill get away from
this he hasn't said anything that we
haven't all been saying for literally
ever this is not new or groundbreaking
information he's charismatic he's not
bad looking and he built a platform
it works for a lot of people I I mean
yeah sure so so you're not even mad that
there's somebody out there saying it
that's the vibe I like that information
as well I'm also I like that information
but what we what we said you know
earlier this week is I will look I will
care about this when they actually go
after Epstein and Maxwell's Client List
no because this is this is to me that's
ridiculous I don't care so no absolutely
you can do more than one thing at once
and you could care about more than one
set of survivors or potential crimes at
once except I agree but what we're
seeing here is this massive
International and corporate press effort
going after this guy and his brother
sure while they have protected along
with the government protected one of the
most egregious trafficking Rings we've
ever seen the survivors of Epstein
deserve justice as well and I believe
that all co-conspirators in in the
Epstein case should be held accountable
as well and so I've served I've served
they're skipping over them I'm sorry I'm
not gonna give them an inch because
they're skipping over absolutely what
you're not understanding is that
sometimes there is a trickle effect
there are still things happening with
the Epstein case and I want to remind
everyone out there watching every time
you think that the Epstein case has done
more happens and you got you know
there's only so much that that the
survivors can do and there's only so
much that they that there's only so much
that that the survivors can do but they
are still fighting trust me this is
nowhere that is nowhere near done you
can't equate one case for another case
there are two totally different cases so
let's hopefully push for justice with
the Epstein Maxwell case and the all
co-conspirators are held accountable but
also you can care about another case and
hope that if if Justice needs to be
received if we could get a little bit of
clarification here I just I also want to
talk about the vice piece a little bit
here but we know what was happening with
Epstein to a certain level which was
really really bad yeah outside of the
legal perspective what do you think was
happening here with the Tate Brothers
what do you think they were doing uh
um how were they running their operation
what was really going on here from your
perspective I'm not going to speak about
that okay I'm sorry I'm very no no no no
no no no just so people understand the
level of like hey what Epstein was doing
was extremely horrible and bad right I
will say taking small children that were
like like Todd like like nine years old
and and then bringing them onto Islands
to you know have other powerful people
fly in do whatever that's really bad so
so how bad from your perspective I know
you you don't have to answer it but how
bad is that related to tastes abuse
isn't like a um
because every human's different abuse
can affect an individual differently uh
so it's not like um there's a word I
want to use right now but it I can't I
just want to keep the show clean like uh
it's not a Tit for Tat game when it
comes to abuse it's not like one abuse
is worse than one abuse I've met
survivors who were sexually assaulted
one time and it's harder on them that
one that one abuse is harder on them
than survivors who have been sexually
abused locked up chained for a very long
time it doesn't so this is we don't play
a Tit for Tat game when it comes to
abuse if you're abused you're abused so
why don't we just let we'll let
everything happen the way it's supposed
to legally and lawfully and we'll I'm
all I'm asking and I get what you're
saying Tim but there's a reason I'm not
part of the machine
I'm not part of the machine I don't even
work for nicosi who's representing the
case
I know I'm I'm not part of the machine
so if I'm sitting here saying I'm
serving to the survivors in fact I've
broken bread with some of the people
that have are really super cool with
Tate so I'm not part of the machine so I
guess the real question is are are folks
going to believe like okay lies is part
of this big conspiracy also I'm not part
of the corporate press in fact quick
reminder to everyone at home I just went
through my uh dregs where I've been
getting dragged by the corporate press
left and right
before we move on to the next story I
wanted to talk about this Vice report
that just also recently came out because
they detailed how seven years ago he was
also accused of sexual sexual assault
and physical abuse in the United Kingdom
but from that case the UK authorities
actually declined to prosecute him and
Tate released the statement about this
specifically through his lawyer while in
Romanian custody saying specifically
that the individuals accusing him were
trying to go after money saying quote
the police understood after the
investigation that I am innocent and the
police found messages from the girls
phones where they were talking between
themselves and planning to lie about me
end quote that's what Andrew Tate said
according to the response of this Vice
report that specifically detailed how he
punched one girl in the arm and
allegedly forced himself on another girl
in in a shower from one of the girls who
was who was seeing it uh the woman also
decided to remain anonymous here but
this Vice report is of course something
that everyone is talking about and
saying this is not the first time he's
being accused of something like this as
well did you see that advice report and
actually if the survivors out there are
listening that step forward and that I
appreciate your bravery and hopefully
um you know I hope you get some justices
as well if it's you know that's I really
appreciate your bravery and actually I
want to say something else I'm sorry for
the way that the internet dragged you
um
and I've been there and it socks and
keep going
keep going and actually reach out to
nicosi law as well because you we can
connect you with some of the survivors
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time